it's the last day of e3 but don't have
no fear because we've got some awesome
games coming on today show joining me
again is Ali rap for Nintendo treehouse
ally what are you showing us today
Xenoblade Chronicles X Xenoblade
Chronicles X so this game came out in
japan in april yep it's already out and
we are finally getting it here in the
west later this year yeah december
fourth of this year yep yep yep and
we'll actually be seeing some of the
english text in this build as well so
the final game will have English taxi
English voices but you know we're still
working on that I don't think like it's
not as easy as just releasing right
right right yeah you should is kind of a
lengthy proof yeah oh my gosh it's such
a massive game and it's huge so what
happened is just as kind of like a recap
on the story is you are you start out on
earth well you know the game is throw
down on earth but a story sucks on on
earth and there are warring aliens who
are fighting over over Earth's no planet
basically and earth is about to be
destroyed and so humanity's trying to
escape on these big arcs these big ships
and one of the ships is called the white
whale and the white whale ends up
crashing over an alien planet as it
flies away and the city of New Los
Angeles which we'll see in a second is
kind of this city that was on the lark
yeah and when they are crashed the city
you know is mostly intact it was
salvageable right right and so a lot of
people that living there are still
living there now on this alien planet
but the rest of the white whale is
strewn across the rest of this i woke up
i guess on entry into the blade yeah
basically and so your job you're part of
what's called blade the organization
blade and as part of blade it's your job
to go out and search for basically these
pieces of the white whale that have you
know broken off and been strewn about
all over the planet and to save any of
the resources that you can as well as
the people who may have been in like
different pods yeah and that's actually
what you are is when you start up the
game elma the character with the white
hair
she finds you in a pod and that's kind
of where your journey starts and so
you're off you know you're salvaging
materials and what we did right now is
we accepted a heart-to-heart quest and
the heart to heart quests are basically
and you are able to kind of see
character backstory yeah you have
opportunities to build relationships
with the party characters and you know
in your party and so that's what we're
going on right now and right now we're
just supposed to collect three parts of
the white whale yeah on the North Point
shore and primordius we're gonna do that
but right now we're seeing a little bit
of new la new Los Angeles yeah so I mean
it looks like a no different no regular
Los Angeles yeah quite a bit me I that
now and I think pink sweater but it does
not look like that maybe in my 20 years
I wonder if the water's any better yeah
I love you la is the best la so we're
seeing new LA right now and then we're
gonna travel to an Aryan primordia to do
this quest and so there are what I think
it's like five continents in this planet
and they're all huge yeah yeah they're
massive they're all super different to
primordia is kind of like this forest
see you know you've got some water areas
mountainous areas but yeah the different
continents all look dramatically
different two in each continent also has
like different wildlife from Florida
verte fauna different items to collect
so you're really gonna want to explore
and what makes that easy is at some
point in the game you get what's called
a skel yeah and a scale is basically a
massive customizable robot that you can
then pilot it's kind of like a
transformer like I just like having your
own transformer yeah actually it it can
travel along the ground and fly as well
that's amazing yeah yeah I mean what
we're seeing here is you're following
the nafal trying yeah yeah yeah we're
using the nav fall um so the nav ball is
something it's basically an unlimited
resource thing that you can send out to
use to see what direction you should
head into your for your objective it's
taking off a quiet pace right right
right um and what's important about the
nap ball is you don't need to use it if
you're like I'm gonna find this on my
own in this
massive continent of you know five on
this planet that's all up to you but you
know if you're kind of interested in
this quest in particular you don't want
to get sidetracked by any of the other
you know tons and tons of quests in the
game you can use the nav ball the
directory where you need to go how else
can we see the environment I mean
because I mean it's beautiful it's a
vast expanse yeah yeah another way of
seeing it all um so actually we can
Sarah can we see kind of like that hover
mode do you remember how to do that I
know we can't there we go there we go
alright so here we're seeing basically
this really really high up view of the
land it makes us able to see like you
know can I travel out there oh I see
land masses on maybe I can swim out
there basically whatever you can see you
can get to yeah as long as you have the
means to do it sometimes you'll need to
scale sometimes you know you might need
there might be too strong enemies to go
there yet but generally if you can see
it you can go there so it's just like
this massive massive massive experience
so is this the first bit of the white
whale that we collecting right now yeah
yeah we're we're collecting some pieces
of the white whale and then we're gonna
see a cutscene where I'm this character
Doug shows up and Doug can be part of
your party um doug is like oh no we're
getting this you know message from Irina
who's another kind of big character in
the game but she's in trouble so we're
going to go off in search of her as soon
as we collect these pieces of the white
whale Oh nailed it 23 so right now we're
we've got three characters well for with
us we've got the protagonist who is your
customizable avatars you know first you
can be a duder lady on tons of
customization options like it's not just
like hair color it's like multiple hair
colors and it's not just like eye color
it's like okay what do you want the
outer part of the eye to be what do you
want to enter part of the idea wow so
lots of cool options and then we've also
got Elma who's the one with the white
hair yeah I'll in the the smaller one
and then tattoo that's his japanese name
he's like the little potato looking guy
i was i was gonna ask about him uh look
what kind of alien races he was he
I can't remember what they're called but
I believe they may have been in
Xenoblade Chronicles I can't remember I
one of those people actually I'm really
interested in seeing like Chronicles X
because I'm one of those people who
missed the original yeah the we um and
you know it just got like fantastic
reviews people loved it and we released
it on the new nintendo 3 s excel I'm a
little bit ago and I just you know we're
preparing for e3 I was playing majora's
mask for you so like I just haven't got
around to it and so I'm really actually
super excited about seeing a conical is
because what's cool about it is you know
if you're a fan of this interplay
Chronicle game um you're going to love
this like there's so much of that kind
of element like all the elements you
love return and then tons of new stuff
as well but if you didn't play that it's
not like it's like a direct sequel you
had me play the first one exactly right
it's super accessible it's from you know
from a story standpoint you don't need
to have like learned the art system in
the first game to get the art system in
this one it'll teach you and so
definitely this is your first time
jumping into Xenoblade Chronicles game
yeah you know don't feel like oh I need
to go back and play that you know the
hundred hours of everything like
chronicles to enjoy this one um so let's
talk a little bit more combat as well
because I um I assume it's a it's an
alien planet they're not just gonna give
up resources yeah willingly yeah you are
we gonna be coming up again um so for
the most part right now we're battling a
creatures and so some creatures are
aggressive and you can tell that based
on that whether they have like that red
icon next to like their name their the
level that they're at so these creatures
up here are sorry there is those
creatures are aggressive because they
have that little red icon some creatures
aren't but of course you can still
attack them so those are your uh one of
your big sets of enemies you do battle
other enemies in the game but that's a
little bit further into the main story
so we won't want to spoil it um like
some areas move it not accessible but
it's you know it kind of it's difficult
to get them if you're not right yeah
yeah so some areas you know might be
hard to get to like if you don't have a
scale some areas there might be like a
level 50 enemy and your only level 5
well if the level 50 enemy is guarding
that like one
asking to that mountain or something
probably not going to want to go there
until you're able to take out that enemy
and so you can even see that there is
enemies just traveling around this area
of primordia that are all different
kinds of levels you see level 12 level
14 I think I saw level 31 yeah level 31
over there we are what level are we can
remember I think we're like level 14 or
so so we're actually gonna go take on a
boss yeah oh yeah do the same level as
we are um so if you played the original
xenoblade chronicles you familiar with
what's called the art system yeah
there's the arts palette and we'll see
that pop up on the lower part of the
screen in just a sec that returns
obviously there's tons of new like
abilities new arts new things to learn
and there's also what's called a battle
cry yeah and so what happens is while
we're battling uh it'll show basically
like oppress be on in the middle of the
screen and you'll also see the little
arts the little circles on the bottom of
your screen glow and if you manage to
press that appropriate button at that
right time you initiate what's called a
battle cry and a battle cry is basically
you or your teammates are saying like oh
the enemy is weak we should move in from
melee attack or oh I need healing so do
this and so what you do is when you
press it in time you'll then get a boost
to something that you did so say it's a
melee attack you might have a more
efficient melee attack ya say that it's
you know I need healing um you might do
that and what's also cool is when you
are successful with those battle cries
you might heal in addition so like it
might be an attack that you do but not
extra health as you're doing it's a good
way to heal during the battle so I see
yeah we're taking on the bus right now
yep yep we getting our first cutscene
action and so it's daytime right now and
what's really cool about this tunnel
here is there's these little like bug
enemies yeah and during the daytime
those bug enemies are not aggressive but
at night they are and so this day night
cycle as well as the weather cycle
actually impacts like what happens
during battle it's also coming like we
aren't if I julio's associated with you
it's like you know great platformer
solid Nintendo but games are kind of all
you know in levels this is just sort of
really open yeah yeah leo
really really open and so in a lot of
ways I think that like if you were
interested in you know this all the game
that coming out next year and you're
like man I'd really love to really
invest some time in a big big game this
winter tryouts newly Chronicles X
because it's got a lot of like it just
is really really big and what's really
cool about it is that if you're like oh
I'm really into this game it looks
really cool I don't have 200 hours to
put into it you might just have 20 or
you might have 40 that's cool too it's
basically see if as you want it to be so
we're actually seeing the Arts palette
right now on the bottom part of the
screen yeah I'm you can see icons that
are glowing that's um you know your
teammates are calling out for a battle
cry this looks basically kind of like
the different abilities that you can do
during battle yeah so what are we gonna
do now we have a couple minutes left
let's try to take this guy out yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm in Sarah I believe in her
she's gonna be awesome she really well
so far oh oh no oh no oh man that's okay
that's okay yeah I wouldn't have been
able to do it on right um so we met we
spoke about this area but when is the
game out december fourth of this year so
just a few more months it's gonna be
great like i said its massive and it's
just like it's a beautiful game and if
you play the original to deploy
chronicles you know that the
environments alone like make the game
worth it it's just it's so gorgeous to
explore there's so much different floor
and fauna that it got the game um it's
just gonna be a great experience it's
already special Wii U gamepad
functionality actually there is um so on
the gamepad one of the things that you
can do while you're exploring is you can
see this kind of grid like a map of what
you know the map looks like and those
are called segments and on the segments
you see things like where named enemies
might be which are more powerful usually
they're part of a quest you can see like
areas to mine for resources you can see
like oh ah I've kind of initiated a
quest here but haven't finished it oh I
should go to that segment to do that so
the gamepad is really really great for
just like keeping track of all the
different things that are you have to
keep track of in a game as massive as
this one oh we're back ahh okay all
right there's goes no pressure at all
yeah no pressure all right so we're
trying to rescue one of the characters
Irina right now okay so how did the
polity members behave during battle so
they just kind of go out at their own
well yeah yeah yeah yeah so unpaid for
the most part will do their own thing
but one of the good ways to you know
kind of encouraged I'm kind of a melding
of you know strategy is with that battle
cries so like you get it it gets really
really like really really detailed in
the menu but you can basically like if
this I'll do a battle cry you should do
this and so you can basically customize
like what kinds of things initiate
battle prize what kinds of things happen
when you do battle cry and they respond
so it's a lot of working together and of
course you also get a lot of that
relationship building that you had any
original seasonably clinicals where when
you do heart-to-heart quest oh good jobs
all right when you do our quests you
know you build relationships with your
party members it impacts the story it
impacts battles so all of that is just
like wrapped up with this huge awesome
really detailed system well I'm ready
got it what a great place to finish demo
as well defeated the boss well done
Sarah ally thank you so much dad having
us um what guys make sure you don't go
in yet more I'm Way alone lose about
whatever 83 um thank you don't go to
have more awesome games coming right up